okay so I was driving home at 2:00 a.m.
the other day or night I wasn't really
paying attention as to how fast I was
going there was no one on the road I
just wanted to get home so of course
there's a speed trap and a cop pulls me
over now when a cop pulls you over you
know he's gonna ask you questions like
you know first you were gone for you
know why I pulled you over because we
all know once he does that it is your
time to shine because you can then plead
your case to try to get out of getting a
ticket so you can avoid the little
annoyances in life like paying higher
insurance premiums not this guy this guy
was all business he was all like I
pulled you over go on fifty three miles
an hour yeah
53 in a freeway god forbid license
registration please so I gave it to him
all right thank you you hang tight
humble back to you in a second yeah
I think I heard him say that last part
but I'm not quite sure so of course he
gives me a ticket a ticket and I even
got some light reading material remember
it's not a race who thinks this huh
and then he sent me on my way never
asked me a question
I couldn't interject plea or even beg
him for mercy now understand I have the
utmost respect for police officers I do
and I don't even blame him because I
realized why I can't get out of tickets
it is my driver's license photo it has
to be when I first got my driver's
license the guy at the DMV took forever
to take my photo he was all like okay
now ready yeah apparently everybody in
my stories has a pornstar moustache but
he just stood there forever he didn't
take my picture so I'm just standing
there and I finally go do you want me to
smile and that's when he took the
picture so my driver's license was all
like dude click and it looks something
like that so whenever I got pulled over
honestly the cop would just be like
let's picture look all right you're
going 542 and a 40 okay I just
okay just be safe out there
all right there a lot of drunks you
don't want to get it right it was back
then go all right good God God oh you're
good go oh I think they would just pity
me because I look like a dumbass so then
one day when I went to get my license
renewed I was like this is not happen
again I will not look the fool again I
will look cool I will look debonair this
picture was gonna be awesome and like
every other human being on the face of
the planet I'm not going to show you my
real picture but I stress to you it's
something like this uh I don't know I
promise you though it is 98% that I have
the same shit-eating smirk on my face
either that kind of look that's like hey
officer how's it going I dare you how's
your daughter so now every cop that
pulls me over sees that picture and
they're like I'll be back for your
ticket momentarily and so the moral of
the story the reason I tell you this is
because if you're gonna get your license
renewed or you're getting a license yeah
don't try to look cool in it why because
you're probably not gonna look cool and
- because it will only cause you misery
tickets and pain the dopey er you look
in your picture the better go out of
your way to look pathetic just have a
picture like that I swear to god no cop
will give you a ticket if you have that
picture pathetic picture equals sympathy
pearls of wisdom I now give to you so I
mean do you guys get pulled over a lot
are you as bad as me and if so how do
you get out of that ticket I need to
know and if you like what you've seen
here click on the link in the sidebar to
see more and maybe subscribe
but honestly drive safe out there and
remember it's not a race
Oh